لم يمر اعلان الرئيس الامريكي السابق
دونالد ترامب ترشحه للانتخابات الرئاسيه
20 24 مرور الكرام رغم انه كان متوقعا بل
منتظرا
وعلى عادته قسم المشهد بين مؤيد جدا
ومعارض جدا انقسام وصل الى داخل عائلته
نفسها
تحديدا ابنته ايفانكا التي لعبت ادوار
الرئيسيه خلال فتره رئاسه والدها الاولى
حيث اعلنت انها لن تكون طرفا بالحمله
الانتخابيه لمحاوله ترامب العوده الى
البيت الابيض معلنه بدبلوماسيه ان
اولويتها اولادها وليس السياسه اما عده
اوصاف في الحزب الجمهوري عكست خيبه املها
وخصوصا انها تلمس تراجع عن واضحا في شعبيه
ترامب
والتي عكسها اخفاق العديد من المرشحين
الذين دعامهم في الانتخابات النصفيه
مفوته الفرصه على الجمهوريين بفوز كبير
اشبه بموجه حمراء او هكذا اردوها لكن
الرئيس الخامسه والاربعين لا يعبا
بالارقام والاحصائيات
ويراهن على اسلوبه في اعاده تجهيس
الناخبين من اجل امريكا العظيمه
[موسيقى]
لنيل بطاقه الترشح للرئاسه
الى معركه ضاربه داخل الحزب الجمهوري
وتحديدا مع بروز وجوه جمهوريه جديده
قويه
في البيت الابيض